good evening good it is a good evening
seeing you all here makes me see the
truth of the old adage that if you make
a poster that is scary enough looking
people will come this evenings round
table deals with the calculus involving
the possibility of war with Iran we have
an all-star group of people here to
discuss it this is taking place under
the sponsorship of the Middle East
Institute and under the constant
planning goading and arranging of Nathan
Stroupe who is really the person who has
who has made this happen tonight I'm
very grateful to Nathan for taking the
initiative in this we enter on this
topic with what is for me a note of
nostalgia throughout the Bush
administration we could rely every six
months on rumors of war with Iran and
you know surveyed January and the fall
phenomenon kind of like the you know the
changing of the seasons that the Sabres
would be rattled the war date would be
planted but you know four to six months
in the future and then those four to six
months would pass nothing would happen
and you would go on and rattle the
sabers again for the next season
we haven't had that kind of saber
rattling in the Obama administration but
actually that doesn't make the issue go
away the saber rattling may have been
theater more than reality it certainly
scared Americans more than it scared the
Iranians but the fact that matter is
Iran is there Iran
continues to be viewed in official
circles and indeed I think in most
public circles in this country as a
threat either near term or long term and
Iran still has a nuclear program
although it's a nuclear program that
reminds one of Zeno's paradox
you know the farther around advances the
goal is always five years away so I
think Gary SiC was the one who said that
it was 17 years ago that the first
prediction came of Iran getting nuclear
weapons within five years and those
predictions have come regularly since
that time but you know at some point
something might actually happen and to
talk about this possibility I'm going to
I want to introduce my three colleagues
here my name is Richard bullet I'm a
professor of history especially
specializing in the Middle East here at
Columbia to my left is dr. Mansour fair
hang-its a professor of international
relations and Middle Eastern politics at
Bennington College in Vermont he served
as the Islamic Republic of Iran's first
ambassador to the United Nations after
the Revolution and worked as a mediator
in the early months of the iran-iraq war
he left Iran as a dissident in 1981 he
is a co-author of u.s. press and Iran
foreign policy and the journalism of
deference deterrence I think is meant
here
deference all right and the author of US
imperialism from the spanish-american
war to the Iranian Revolution to his
left is gentlemen I have known since
graduate school days John Limbert dr.
John Limbert he is a professor of
international affairs at the United
States Naval Academy in Annapolis and a
former diplomat most recently serving as
the deputy assistant secretary for Iran
at the State Department's Bureau of Near
Eastern affairs before joining the
Foreign Service John taught in Iran both
as a Peace Corps volunteer
and as an English and structure
instructor at Shiraz University he has
authored numerous articles on Middle
Eastern subjects and three books Iran at
war with history
Shiraz in the age of ha Fez which was
his doctoral dissertation and most
recently negotiating with Iran and to
his left is Gary SiC dr. Gary SiC got
his PhD here at Columbia he has a senior
research scholar in the Middle East
Institute here at Columbia an adjunct
professor of international public
affairs is the author of all fall down
America's tragic encounter with Iran and
October Surprise America's hostages in
Iran in the election of Ronald Reagan
gary served on the National Security
Council under presidents Ford Carter and
Reagan and was the principal White House
aide for Iran during the Iranian
Revolution and the hostage crisis as we
plan this and trying to decide how to
how to proceed we eventually decided
that everybody would give an opening few
minutes of reflections on the topic but
before we came to that conclusion
I had actually formulated three focused
questions which I'm going to read not
for the benefit of the panel but rather
for the benefit of the audience perhaps
to orient you to some of the issues
involved the first one is given that
none of us know with any certainty
whether Iran has a nuclear weapons
program what are the arguments within
Iran for and against such a program how
powerful are these arguments in shaping
internal political dynamics the second
question given the belief that belief in
a threat from Iran is central to the
thinking of many Israeli policy makers
and citizens to what degree does this
concern reflect inward issues as opposed
to a credible calculus of Iranian
ideology and intent and three some
American commentators feel that an
attack on Iran would provoke a minimal
harmful response from Iran and that
their purported nuclear weapons program
would be cut back at negligible cost
other analysts feel that the Iranian
capacity for punishing us action is very
high what is your appraisal of these two
approaches in other words I was trying
to formulate questions that would focus
on an Iranian perspective an Israeli
perspective an American professor
perspective thinking of these as the
most important factors here although
obviously the Saudis and various other
parties Europeans have a opinion on this
matter but without more ado I'm going to
turn to Mansour and ask him to give some
opening remarks thank you very much it's
an honor to be here let me first say
categorically that I am an opponent of
the Iranian regime in fact I actually
dream of regime change in Iran but I'm
actually committed to the position that
any effort to bring about regime change
in Iran from without is going to lead
from bad to worse so the kind of regime
change I have in mind is peaceful
democratic and it absolutely has to come
from within and regrettably I will not
be living to see it even though one
could make a logical case based and
disturb the evidence that the Iranian
regime is on the self-destructive course
but it will not be while I'm on this
planet let me just say a few words the
term Iran nuclear in a program returns
nearly seven million results in the
Google web search literally it's SEP of
nearly seven million and Iran claims
that over the past 15 years and perhaps
even further since 1984 when Iran
decided to revive its nuclear program
because of Khomeini bars for many was
categorically opposed to the
continuation of the Iranian nuclear
program which Shah
started for the obvious reason that
editing the shot had done was by
definition bad and had to be bad so in
1984 they revived it and since then Iran
claimed that its nuclear program is for
peaceful purposes we have all heard the
United States accuses Iran of wanting to
make nuclear weapons there is this
suspicion and Israel accuses Iran of
wanting to make nuclear weapons and
using them against the Jewish state
Iran is unlikely to give up its nuclear
enrichment program for good the United
States and Israel are not due to accept
Iran has not only actual but even the
potential nuclear weapon universe state
implicit in US and Israeli position is
the determination that Israel should
remain the sole nuclear weapon state in
the Middle East and therefore have
uncontested freedom to use military
force as it sees fit this is the way not
only the Iranians but many players even
American allies in the Middle East view
the situation at the present time Iran
is the only country in the region that
is challenging this hegemonic position
of the United States and the Israel
therefore the United States and Israel
preference can only be the state of
affairs it can only be the rule in the
region through force or threat of force
it would be very difficult to persuade
the players in the Middle East region
that the situation the United States and
Israel prefer is acceptable or serves
the interest so far the Iranian regime I
repeat the regime and not necessarily
obviously the Society has been able to
use the confrontation
with the United States both to its
domestic and regional advantage
domestically it has assisted the regime
to create coherence within the regime
and also use this the enemy without to
suppress dissident elements needless to
say the Iranian theocrats would suppress
the dissident elements the critics of
the regime regardless of the
circumstances but there is no question
that confrontation with the United
States and the constant threat of using
military force against Iran has been
helpful to the regime in justifying its
repressive apparatus at least to its own
constituency and to its own social based
so the reality is that the more threat
we see against Iran the more stubborn
and adamant Iran's rulers will become in
defending the position regionally the
dispute has helped the Iranian rulers to
present themselves as the champion of
Palestinian cause and humiliation of not
only the Arab Street but also the Arab
basement where the elite engaged in
conversation and and discourse that the
confrontation with Israel and the United
States for people who are weak and
humiliated and definitely incapable of
taking strong in a position against what
they perceive to be an imposition or
expansion is giving Iranians definitely
prestige in whatever it is worth that's
it as a separate matter and at the same
time I would say Israel is also
benefiting in my opinion from this
confrontation because this confrontation
is helping Israel to distract attention
from its expansionist policy territorial
expansion ISM on the West Bank and its
effort to contain or suppress
Palestinian you know resistance the
losers in this confrontation
the Iranian people that there is no
question that the Iranian the sanctions
have definitely been hurtful and even
when we read a statistical evidence with
respect to unemployment and inflation in
the government-controlled newspapers of
Iran we can make a very clear and
convincing case that sanctions have
definitely heard the metaclass and the
more the lower middle class and the poor
people begin in Iran now this
convergence of and another losers in my
opinion are American corporations that
they have no access to this important
market and Iranian czar desperate
particularly with respect of
modernization of the of their energy in
the industry they really want to deal
with the universes American all
companies but American they they have
they have no access so I would say
American corporations and the Iranian
people are the losers in this
confrontation while the regime in Iran
the regime both in terms of its ability
to rule as well as the accumulation of
wealth for the newly rich in Iran this
confrontation has been fundamentally you
know helpful and this convergence of
interest between the most hardline
political forces in Iran and the
Washington and Tel Aviv faced hawkish
proponents of regime change you in Iran
is obviously unintended it's incidental
and this strange bedfellow ship reminds
me of the same situation that existed
during the hostage crisis that is in the
United States the bush the Reagan Bush
campaign team the obviously but they
would never admit it but they were very
much interested in humiliation of
President Carter and defeat of President
Carter and defeat of President Carter in
Iran had become the single most
important objective of ayatollah
khomeini
both with respect to its domestic
position as well as regional president
once again during the hostage crisis we
have convergence and confluence of
interest that could
denied because it would be very
difficult to prove it but nevertheless
it was a reality that existed at the
time and it exists today I believe that
even when I genuinely believe that it is
possible to find a diplomatic solution
for this conflict and problem Iran it's
a repressive society the human rights
situation in Iran is abominable
and yet the Iranian regime wants respect
the Iranian regime wants recognition the
the paradox of our culture the political
culture which is by no means limited to
the existing regime is that on the one
hand we take pride in our past at the
same time we are constantly talking
about victimization of the Iranian
society and these two are at war often
with each other and in this regime
coming from the base of the society in
his body his reaction to reposition in
some sense it really reflects the
national psychology of the society in a
very destructive in a very ugly fashion
but nevertheless it's rooted in the
psychology of the country at large and
when at Medina George again comes here
and says 9/11 was invented by certain
factions within the US government and he
gets so much publicity yep John has done
a wonderful job of explaining the
conspiracy theory in his chapter in the
chapter in his excellent you know book
but he is not in when it comes to
conspiratorial thinking about events
Ayatollah Khomeini
the Shah of Iran and Ahmadinejad and
many Iranians living in Los Angeles or
in Tehran are in complete agreement the
Shah of Iran is the Shah of Iran died
believing as it is in his book answer to
history believing that the CIA under oil
companies overthrew him and there is one
fascinating passage in Cynthia Helms who
was the wife of the Richard Helms who
was the American ambassador in Iran she
has written an excellent book about your
onion culture and society also in the
last paragraph of that book
right said she and her husband came to
New York City to visit the shop after he
had been admitted to the United States
and she explains as soon as we entered
the room the Shah sat on the bed had
turned to Richard Helms and said what
did you do this to me I have been your
friend it's a fascinating paragraph at
the end of that book it's called an
ambassador's wife so what did what I
what we said that the rhetoric of Ahmed
in Iran should not be the basis of
finding out the motives of of you and
there are many cases over the past 10 15
years that the Iranians were ready to
negotiate and they were revived then we
don't want to get into that there was
another situation that President Clinton
toward the end of his administration he
made a genuine effort to negotiate at
that time he was rebuffed by the
Iranians because they didn't want her to
me to get the credit for rapid world of
engagement with with the United States
so I genuinely believe that if and one
thing that I've been a member of Amnesty
International since nineteen dues-paying
members since 1963 and I have immense
respect and love for human rights watch
but let me say for the very first time
in my life that the United States should
not at all pay attention to the human
rights situation inside the country
leave that question to NGOs because
pressuring Iran and accusing them of
human rights violations they can come
back and counter that argument for
pointing that to so many human rights
situation in the Middle East region that
the United States seems to be
indifferent in other words at the
present time the United States does not
have the kind of moral credibility that
would push the Iranian regime with
respect to the human rights issue so a
more realistic approach to Iran
recognition of Iran's history
recognition of Iran's desire for
acknowledgement of its role in the
Middle East region particularly in the
Persian Gulf region would be the basis
for a negotiated settlement that would
recognizes Iran's right to enrich
uranium to the level that is necessary
for internal reactors but
the complete and unconditional control
at least for a period of five years or
ten years that it is possible to reach
that kind of agreement with Iran if the
American approached world Iran goes
through a qualitative change and puts
the threat military threat against Iran
on the side and of course the
difficulties are many and John knows a
great deal about them but I think it is
a real possibility to do that thank you
John Limbert well thank you thank you
very much and thank you dick for for the
invitation and dr. will I share dr. Farr
hangs views about the desire for a more
humane and open government in Iran I am
what is often called in in American
circles a moderate in my views now in
the under the previous administration I
should say that a moderate I think was
someone who believed that we should bomb
Iran tomorrow and when when I when I
went to work for the Department of State
about a year ago a year ago and I I
didn't a nine-month stint there and in
the near in the near East Bureau
although some of the commentary on the
blogosphere was was favorable my
favorite some one of the negative
comments was my god we've appointed the
Manchurian candidates to go work on
Iranian to go work on Iranian affairs I
was very struck by the the poster for
this meeting and I don't know if others
had the same associations that I did but
that to me that recalled a very
unfortunate and shameful chapter in
us-iranian relations and there hasn't
been much to be proud of over the
last 30 years but this was a
particularly shameful chapter in which
the US and others and the international
community in general remained silent
when the Iraqis used poison gas during
during the war and whatever the cause
was and whatever you thought of the Gov
of the government remaining silent in
such a situation I think was a shame was
a shameful act and what this did was to
feed into something that dr. Fang
pointed to which is the sense of
victimization and the sense that the
world paid no attention when injustice
was done injustice was done to us now
one of the questions asked here is what
are the arguments within Iran for and
against such a program well if I knew
that I wouldn't be had just been a mere
Deputy Assistant Secretary of State I
would have been way up there someone
somewhere in the higher regions of
regions of knowledge but what is
interesting is to me is to listen to
some of the commentary coming from the
Islamic Republic on on the subject
particularly from the president who who
says well of course we do not want a
nuclear weapon nuclear weapons are evil
nuclear weapons have no use but to kill
nuclear weapons are expensive they serve
no political purpose but if that the
decision to build or not build a nuclear
weapon is our decision and nobody can
tell us what to do and it relates to a
point of sight - a point of psychology
and I think everyone in this room will
know that if you tell someone that a
certain thing is unacceptable and that
he can't have it he's
obviously put a value on it and provokes
the idea well this thing must be of some
value and maybe it's worth what it's
it's worthwhile to pursue but again it
gets back to this question of respect
and national pride and position in the
world which is to say no we don't want
it but you can't tell us we can't have
it that will be ours um our decision
I'll make one last comment and then save
time for I think the quite the questions
of which I'm sure there are many
excellent ones from the off from the
audience and just pointing to this last
one about some American commentators
feel an attack on Iran would provoke a
minimum a minimal harmful response
well what commentators this is I suppose
a symptom of what certainly we see in
Washington which is the what I call the
think tank disease where there is a
there is a culture of no accountability
you can say things you simply can say
anything you want and particularly in
this in this case you may be right you
may be wrong but if you're wrong there
seems to be no there seemed to be no
consequences and I don't know who's
making this pretty I don't know who's
making this prediction I don't know
who's making it on one basis there's a
there's a wonderful expression in
Persian you say mission is sight so the
can ought to go to get language gone sit
at you sit in the peanut gallery and
give advice and say go get him go out
there and get it go out there and get
him and this is a little bit in that in
that case I would wish that those those
commentators or experts or pundits or
whatever we call them whatever we call
them who make such statements would
bring up their evidence explain why they
make such a statement and
and be held accountable for what they
what they say thank you John
I I looked at that poster and saw
something quite different I saw the list
of the order of name so I knew that I
was going to be the last speaker along
the way and I also knew because of my
enormous respect for my colleagues here
that there would be very little left for
me to say when we got to this point so I
hope you will indulge me because I'm
going to tell you a little story it is
related to what we're talking about what
we're talking about here is should the
United States in conjunction with or
otherwise with Israel attack Iran is
that is that a reasonable is that
something that we should anticipate and
I that is what this is about and that's
why you're all here probably I had a
number of emails in the last couple of
days after the news got out that this
was going to this was going to happen
saying you know I'm terribly worried
about the fact that there that there may
be a war with Iran and I wish I could be
there or I'm going to be there or what
have you let me just make a couple of
comments first of all I would like you
to cast your mind back all the way to
February of 2006 can you think back that
far I think when I usually give my
classes I'm dealing with things that
happened when I was you know in the
White House and all of my students that
were not warned at that time and so I'm
not accustomed but it by 2006 you should
all have been around at that time and
that was five just about five years ago
a little less than five years ago
in February of 2006 just to set the
stage a little bit the International
Atomic Energy Agency had just decided
the board had just decided to refer Iran
to the Security Council for basically
what turned out to be a series of
sanctions
and resolutions telling Iran to stop
doing what it was doing that was of
course of the time of George Bush
administration they had they had invaded
Afghanistan it invaded Iraq there had
been a huge bombing in Iraq the samara
bombing in which hundreds actually
almost 2,000 people were killed and a
civil war was breaking out in iraq the
president of the united states george
bush you may recall that name was in
fact approaching his lowest point of
support in the entire history of his
presidency thirty-four percent at that
point and a lot of people felt that he
was really quite desperate that things
were really going very badly he was
surrounded by a group of people many of
the people who are now in the think
tanks and making the commentaries that
john just referred to who were telling
him the answer to this is go ahead and
finish the job take care of iran and
that will that will put you back on
track again and at that point in 2006 i
was invited to go and meet with a group
of financial traders I had never met a
roomful of financial traders before the
incentive was that they met in a really
wonderful place obviously a lot of money
was involved and they flew me to Nassau
and we met in the Atlantis Hotel and if
you've never been there I really
recommend it huh I haven't been back I
can't afford it but you know it was
really terrific and for this meeting
they asked me to talk about the chance
of a war with Iran and the it was kind
of interesting when I got there because
we met in this
cavernous room I mean it really was like
a enormous ballroom and there were two
peculiar things about a one it was
fairly dark and two there must have been
I don't know seven hundred craters there
sitting every one of them had a screen
in front of him in which he was watching
the movement of the bond market or
whatever it was that they watch and my
job they gave me ten minutes which
actually is twice as much as I get
tonight they they gave me ten men they
paid me better they gave me ten minutes
to try to grab the attention of those
folks and not only that but they had had
a vote before I came into the room about
whether the United States would attack
Iran now these are people who don't make
casual judgments they put money behind
their judgments and it actually
determines the way they buy and sell so
I had 10 minutes to try to get their
attention
and so I gave my little 10 minutes feel
during which time the you know I
couldn't tell if anybody was listening
or not but it was quiet at least because
if you're watching a screen there's not
much to talk about you that you aren't
going to be conversing with it in any
event I gave my little speech and my
little speech basically said that this
would not just be a bad idea that this
would be a catastrophe and it would be a
catastrophe of such magnitude that the
United States would be infinitely worse
off than it is than it was at that time
and that any regime any US government
regardless of who was in it and at that
point you will recall it was really
being run by Rumsfeld and and Cheney
that they would look at the evidence
they would look at the circumstances
which were quite well known they were
not hard to figure
and they would come to the conclusion
that they would only make things worse
rather than better
so I said quite clearly unmistakeably it
wasn't going to happen
there was going to be no war now it
turned out what was embarrassing about
this is that the fellow who was the
political analyst for that group that
was that was sponsoring the traders
there in this lovely hotel was a guy who
had been on the National Security
Council staff just a little bit after
I'd been there and he had decided that
there absolutely was going to be an
attack by the administration that
nothing would stop them that this was
the moment that they would do it it was
they had two years before the next
presidential election Israel was pushing
them hard all of the keys were in that
direction I didn't realize that that was
his position until just before I gave
this talk but I was saying exactly the
opposite thing and at the end of the
meeting they took another vote and I was
a little scared you know but they did
take a vote and it turned out that there
had been a substantial shift and now at
least a majority I've forgotten what the
actual numbers were had decided that
there probably wouldn't be a war with
Iran and this was all focused on just
one year just the year ahead up I I
mentioned this because I have continued
to take that view ever since that time
and my personal view at this point is
that if it really because a lot of
people thought in 2006 that Bush was
crazy and that certainly Cheney and
Rumsfeld were crazy and that that
rationality would have nothing to do
with their decision that it was all
ideology today I think you can say with
some conviction that the administration
in Washington may be wrong about things
but it's not crazy and that it is not
going to behave in a totally irrational
way so my own view right now is that
we're not going to have a war with Iran
and we're not going to have one with
Israel is not going to lead a war and
we're not going to be involved in it so
I may end up being wrong but at least
I'm consistent and so I offer you that
just to let you know where I stand at
the very beginning and there are a whole
set of really interesting questions
buried in these three issues that they
put out at the beginning and I'm looking
forward very much to the questions
because I think they're going to be
really terrific and I'll step back and
wait for the questions thank you okay
okay before I open the floor to
discussion I'm going to make three
observations my own well my first
observation really is that I'm really am
busy envious of Gary when money people
asked me about war with Iran I get a
free lunch in Midtown and and a limo
ride and maybe a hundred bucks so it
shows that it makes a big difference
Gary actually changes mind's eye I don't
think I ever do but the obvious vision
observations I want to make first is
based on three weeks that I spent in
Israel in the spring as part of a
committee reviewing the the academic
Middle East history programs Middle East
Studies programs in five Israeli
universities and one of the things that
was most startling was that even though
there were many conversations that I was
party to here and there either during
these visits or outside the visits
including with people in the government
Iran was always coming up as
an existential threat to Israel to the
best of my recollection Israel currently
has a total of five professors who are
knowledgeable about Iran their ability
to study Iran is minimal while they
still are focused massively on studying
Lebanon Jordan Syria Egypt in other
words preparing to fight the last five
wars and there was this paradox between
the population and the government
feeling that here is this imminent
threat but the Academy having little to
do with it of the five people I can
recall who were specialists on Iran one
had written a book called Iran o phobia
tried to explain the bizarre and
irrational character of air of Israel's
fear of Iran this is Professor nametag i
rom at ben-gurion University
another one was whom I won't name was
debating the question of whether he
could actually get away with writing a
book
commenting on the on the positive and
intelligent writings of Ayatollah
Khomeini because he he was in the
process of reading the collected works
of Khomeini and he said you know this is
a pretty smart man has written some
interesting things but my friends tell
me I can't I can't write anything
favorable about him because he wouldn't
write any favorable anything favor about
Israel and then so this was a problem
for him could he write such a book and
as I think of the five not a single one
of them was really a hawk on on Iran and
it made me wonder at the what the inputs
were we talked about think tanks and you
know crazy people here and so I wonder
on the Israeli side what the quality is
of the inputs that go into the I don't
wonder i fact I
I have a very low regard for the quality
of the inputs that go into the obsession
with Iran that you have in Israel the
second observation a couple of weeks ago
I was at a meeting with a deputy head of
the Arab League and the question is
asked if Iran gets a nuclear weapon will
there be an arms race in the Arab world
and he said absolutely unquestionably
you'll have half a dozen countries that
will move immediately to acquire nuclear
weapons that would that Iran would
trigger the nuclearization of the Middle
East and it must be stopped not because
it's a threat to Israel but because it
would turn the region into a nightmare
of nuclear competition personally I
think that is not true but but it's
interesting to see a highly-placed
Arab who who feels that way the third
observation I make is that recently I
was reading about the build-up to the
war with Iraq and one of the things that
became apparent as you look back and I
think we all know this is that after
1991 the u.s. put sanctions on Iraq that
were essentially sanctions that could
not be positively satisfied
you know Iraq could say okay we have
completely given up WMD and we would say
we don't believe you and and the only
way we can be sure is to is to get rid
of of your regime it's sort of like
aliens you know get into outer space and
nuke them from from there the only way
to be sure my worry is that we're moving
a little bit in this direction with Iran
that we are creating a focus on a
sanctions regime that it may not be
possible for Iran ever to satisfy the
the fears of the people who are putting
on the sanctions because right now for
exam
well if you had a statement by Iran that
we have stopped that we have stopped
purifying uranium you would have some
people would say well underground
someplace they're still doing it they're
hidden facilities there are other nuke
there are centrifuges going day and
night to create a weapon we just don't
know where they are they're in Saddam's
palaces which have now been shipped to
Iran presumably and and under that
circumstance you kept to a logic that
say if if you if you sanction a regime
to get it to change its behavior but you
do not believe there are any
circumstances under which a claim to
behavior change would actually be
credible then regime changes you're only
your only option so my worry is that not
next year not six months from now but
over the next five or ten years
particularly as we move into
presidential elections in this country
you may have the same sort of debates
that arose at the time of the glorious
election where both parties are saying
we really have to do something now
finally about Iran so I've always been
with Gary and saying I don't think a war
is imminent I don't think a war is
imminent but I'm not sure that in the
long term the war is actually avoidable
without profound changes within Iran of
the sort that I'm I'm sorr intimated now
I think that rather than talked to each
other at this point it would be better
to open this up to questions from the
audience there is a microphone here in
the center if you line up at the
microphone we will take the questions as
they as they arise this is a very
interesting discussion my name is Carl
Meyer I'm the editor at large the world
policy journal and in two years we're
going to celebrate the 50th mark the
50th
of the Cuban Missile Crisis you can say
that nuclear weapons or the threat of
owning nuclear weapons has one great
virtue you have a bargaining lever the
Cubans got out of it the equivalent of a
non-aggression pact for 50 years we have
not threatened or under 7 different
presidents to try and use a regime
change by violent means against Cuba my
question is wouldn't it make sense for
the u.s. explicitly to offer the
Iranians the equivalent of a
non-aggression pact in exchange for
ironclad guarantees because they would
then be getting what's accept the North
Koreans are trying to get and what other
countries threatening to have nuclear
weapons are trying to get thank you who
wants to respond to that I think such a
gesture would give Iran a kind of
recognition in in the region of politics
that would be very appealing to Iranian
leaders but the negotiation with Iran is
not going to be easy and there is not
going to be an all-encompassing
agreement with Iran but it will be very
incremental very gradual but I genuinely
believe knowing some of the players that
fundamentally it is power it is the
survival of the regime which motivates
these people let me give you one
specific example in the early period of
a value of four it was about four months
into the war I was involved in
negotiations and if you soon came to
realize that all these international
mediators were really useless because
Khomeini was committed to continuing the
war simply because the UN resolution
passed six days after September 22nd
1980 instead of condemning Iraqi
invasion of Iran it simply asked for
ceasefire in place which was really
abominable it was understandable that
the United States was angry with Iran
Iran has committed the horrendous form
of
she's taking and yet in terms of
rational long term foreign policymaking
accepting the invasion of one country by
another very much but Saddam had done on
August 1st 1990 against Kuwait so Eve
onions came to see themselves in a very
in in a way that they are no different
that this victimization business was
reinforced at that moment so and yet
when Iran needed the spare parts for its
helicopters and it was american-made
experiments it happy factory who was
Colonel factory he was Minister of
Defense at the time they realized that
they would get the spare parts in Europe
from a black market and yet he did not
want to do that without jimenez
permission and he told me specifically
that he went to see Khomeini when there
were 14 people in the room and he is
specifically told how many years we do
have these spare parts but we think they
were coming from Israel Khomeini said
are the salesmen Israelis they said no
the Portuguese British and Italian and
for many estate we are not religiously
obligated to ask him where they get
emergency examples that the man was
really at Bob Couvillion
political manager manager of power and
so is Ahmadinejad contrary to the idea
that he is crazy fanatic he is a
rational character with respect to his
he is very egotistical and he's enjoying
the attention he is getting here but the
decisions he makes with respect to the
advancement of his own interests and the
people around him these are pretty
rational decisions I would assume if the
United States approaches Iran if this
engagement is genuine with recognition
of Iran's respect for Iran and replicate
knowledge meant of Iran's role in the
Middle East region in the Persian Gulf
region Iranian response to it would be
positive very very briefly in a in a
better world your suggestion is makes
perfect sense
and implicitly I think I think President
Obama did make such a suggestion
particularly when he spoke and in his
first Nowruz message speaking both to
the Iranian people and to the government
and to the government which was a major
symbolic major change when he spoke
about mutual mutual respect however
things have not gone well in in response
and I I don't know why I would like to
know why I mean there are I have I have
ideas and their their many their many
ideas but I would only quote a an
Iranian official official of the Islamic
Republic not a not an opposition figure
not an academic academic but this wasn't
a an official of the Islamic Republic
he's quoted by I think Kareem said poor
and the the analyst quotes him as saying
you know he said if we cannot make nice
with with a Barack Hussein Obama who
speaks to us a mutual respect who quotes
Persian poetry to us who sends us
greetings on Nowruz then there is a
problem and the problem is not in
Washington and this was coming this
coming from an Iranian sitting Iranian
official so there is some there is some
difficulty at the at the bar at the
bottom I think people recognize this and
recognize that this is way is coming
it's it's getting there that has proved
particularly hard I'm probably not a
good idea for all three of us to answer
each question but I but this was a this
covered a lot of territory actually and
it actually gets to the heart of things
when dick bullet was describing a moral
dilemma
that we've defined the Iranian regime in
such a way that no matter what they do
we have to get rid of them before
anything can move on and the Iranians I
think have defined us in a way that in
many ways is the same sword and it means
the real question then is how do you get
out of it where did you go and your
suggestion about a non-aggression pact
is certainly a reasonable one I would
aim for a little bit lower than that and
I think actually Mansour actually
outlined very briefly the contours of
what that kind of a situation would look
like and to me we've got to remember the
Shah also had a nuclear program and he
was going someplace with it and people
suspected at the time that he was going
to be building a nuclear weapon that was
very strongly suspected all of his aides
today claimed that what he was really
after was to have a breakout capability
a capacity to build a bomb but without
actually having one and in reality you
can get the same kind of respect that
people talk about with the bomb if
people know that you have the capacity
to get it very quickly that's all you
really need so the idea that you can in
fact then give them the capacity to go
on making enriching uranium and have
that infrastructure there so that people
recognize it and understand it but at
the same time have a very close watch on
what they're doing seems to me a
reasonable compromise what it does is
solve the problem on both sides we're
never going to be happy that it's a
hundred percent observation but the
reality is if they decide to break out
and go for a bomb with our people their
inspectors all we're likely to know that
about the time it happens and if you can
negotiate something that keeps them not
three weeks away from a bomb
but let's say a year or 18 months which
is reasonable then you have early
warning and you have time to respond in
some kind of policy way and to me that
is the kind of an objective that you can
aim at at this stage with a good deal
more assurance that you're going to get
a reaction from the Iranians the problem
is we've again talked ourselves into a
corner on that that every time we make
we talk about Iran and enrichment we've
made it an absolute redline that Iran
must stop enriching uranium completely
they're never going to do that so either
we're serious about negotiating or we're
not and to me you start with that early
stage we toyed with that idea last year
and then backed away from it because the
political fallout in this country was
too powerful but the reality is it is a
solution out there waiting to be taken
and it's one that Iran might very well
grab not because they love us or because
they're willing to deal with us but
because it's in their interest to
maintain that capability and to get
themselves out of the sanctions box the
theory in presently next question yes
my name is Roger Pugh Lima the UN
representative of lawyers Without
Borders I and my questions may reflect
some prejudices but what would you think
of the United States not using
recognition as a bargaining chip but
just recognizing we're working towards
recognizing Iran and secondly I don't
think anybody spoke explicitly of a
likelihood of Israeli starting a war
without our support
let me comment just a moment on the
second part of it when the the UN
ambassador
prior to the current one was leaving his
position there was a group of people who
got together for lunch and I raised a
question as to whether an Israeli attack
on Iran that the US did not have
anything to do with would be understood
in Tehran as being an attack by the
United States and he said yes and it was
very very forceful that I said yes
absolutely it would because the Iranians
do not believe that Israel can stage an
attack that the u.s. either does not
condone or support or at least have
prior knowledge of so the idea of a
totally independent Israeli attack I
don't think it's an impossibility
I just am Not sure that the Iranians
would agree that it is a that it is a
possibility
could I just add one point to that and
that is that if Israel decides to act on
its own and everybody is really worried
about that they are facing a real
existential crisis because their real
existence is determined and is supported
by the United States and if they risk
giving up that break that bond
with the United States it might or it
might not but it might and if I were now
if I were the you know Prime Minister of
Israel and I knew that that was one of
the potential costs that would go with
it one the operation isn't going to work
without American support you'll make a--
you'll do a pinprick you'll draw america
into a war but you won't solve your
problem and the secondly you may in fact
alienate the administer
in Washington to such a degree that you
quit getting the kind of support that
you depend on for your very existence if
that's the choice
my guess is Israel isn't going to do it
and that's oh my logic he carries on up
with regard to your other question about
negotiation about recognition as a lever
it's really a very good question and
it's one that has plagued the Americans
for a long time because you know the
British in some other countries tend to
recognize a country regardless whether
they like it or not they just say there
it is we have to deal with it and they
recognize it we're a little more choosy
than that and especially in this
particular case where we broke relations
with Iran over the hostage crisis it's
very difficult to then go back and
restore them curiously the the last time
that I'm aware of that we had a serious
discussion of that subject in Washington
was the last two years of the Bush
administration when in fact although
nobody paid any attention to it there
was a dramatic shift of policy Cheney
was in effect marginalized Rumsfeld was
fired Bob gates came in who was a very
different sort of Secretary of Defense
Condoleezza Rice was running the State
Department and was whispering in Bush's
ear a very different set of messages
they were beefing up their control over
their their their coverage of Iran a lot
of things were going on and they raised
the issue quite clearly of establishing
a intersection an American man
intersection in Iran and that was really
revolutionary in my view and it was
bruited about in the press they never
denied it and the Iranians even said
they didn't think it was such a bad idea
so we had a possibility there
nobody ever followed through I mean
nobody in Washington followed through
and I think I can give you my reason for
that which is that by the time they got
around to it in the near the end of the
Bush administration there was another
presidential campaign going on and Don
McCain was running for president and
John McCain was talking about bombing
Iran and he was going to talk about how
tough he could be on Iran and for them
to come along the Bush administration at
that point and establish in effect
low-level diplomatic relations with Iran
would have undercut his position totally
and as far as I can tell they just
backed away from it but that is my
conspiracy theory it may or may not be
true but at least the timescale is
correct in any case we didn't go through
with it and that is a but I do think
that using that as a as an entry point
rather than as a club to bash it wrong
with is actually quite a good idea in
another aspect of this situation that
creates real problems in Iran's
perception of the glass
the Iranian bruders analyst I with the
Iranian newspapers regularly the studies
they do in the parliament and elsewhere
they really do not have an appreciation
for the diversity and complexity of
American politics and society they'd sit
they assume that whatever happens in the
United States is highly centralized and
purposeful that I've been Giuliani for
example and john bolton come before the
united nations in support of an
organization which was a tool of
Septimus in for 15 years and they speak
about regime change maneuver in iran
they are not going to see this as a kind
of idiosyncratic margin of political
activity in the United States by two
politicians who are engaged in
cooperation with this empowered an
organization they see it as American so
it's or when Congress a big a
significant number of members of
Congress pass a resolution and give
Israel a blank check a quarter branch
that if you feel threatened you have
every right to attack your
they are not going even yinz are not
going to see this as one group of
Representatives in the United States who
might have an opinion maybe they are
using it for their own domestic
political purposes they again they are
seeing it as an American action this is
a reality that it's not only in Iran but
in the entire Middle East and it's a
reality Robert Lipton has written a
fascinating book called perceptions and
misperceptions in international
relations that in with respect to this
confrontation between Iran and the
United States this misperception is
really a source of destruction and real
danger in this confrontation Tom do you
want to I want to hear the questions
okay Frank my question actually related
my name is Leila Darby and I'm a
contributor to the website Tehran Bureau
and I've been very interested tonight in
the conversation about think tanks
versus policy advisers and the quality
of information that one side has about
another and I was wondering what all of
your current perceptions are of the
inputs on the American side and how you
would characterize the conversations
between the State Department and the
White House right now when it comes to
making decisions about Iran but who are
having these conversations that we're
talking about who are making the
decisions it's a great question I spent
nine months in the State Department I
wish I knew someone asked me they said
who's who's running who's running Iran
policy in the US government all I could
say was I know who isn't running Iran
policy in the US come in yes or no there
is a there is a problem and I I say this
half facetiously that you know in in
Washington now anybody with with a
decent suit becomes an Iran expert and
one reason for that is something that
others have have pointed to and that is
the lack of communication the lack of
dialogue the lack of any official back
and of any official back and forth of
which leads
two things well first of all with no
with no embassy on the ground and no
people there there's no one who can say
to the gentleman that dr. Fang mentioned
your I your ideas are hogwash we're here
and here's what we see and here's and
this is what and this is what we hear we
don't have that so when you're not
communicating when you're not talking
what happens you build an image of the
other side that is simultaneously
superhuman and subhuman and it is in
which and so it's very easy to do this
and so when this happens at the same
time the superhuman you fear the
subhuman you despise and this is this is
the culture of ignorance or lack of
information or misinformation or
deliberate partisan agendas that I was
referring to my name is Jani Roberts I'm
from yani issue it's from NYU's Center
for Global Affairs and well I'm from
Israel my question is it seems like it's
kind of easy to belittle the the threat
when you're thinking only of a doom days
scenario but then you mentioned that
Arabs I think also Israelis are afraid
of an arms race and a nuclear arms race
and then even before that you could
expect terrorist organizations to be
emboldened by a nuclear Iran and even
before that I think you see already now
that with huge arms deal between Saudi
Arabia and the
and responding to that a huge Israeli
deal with the US that it's very likely
that it wouldn't have taken place
otherwise I'm just wondering what do you
think about the threat when you look at
it that way thank you could I just say
that I I really do understand why people
in Israel are concerned about Iran I
think they have every reason to be
concerned not only because of the
nuclear threat which i think is really a
sort of false flag I think really the
danger is more likely to come from
Hezbollah or from Hamas or or from some
other regional source rather than
suddenly an Iranian missile arriving
with a nuclear weapon on it when they
don't have the missiles and they don't
have nuclear weapons that will fit on
them it did this and won't have for a
very long time but the threat is real
and there's another way to look at it
too and that is and mostly people don't
look at it this way that Israel and Iran
are in fact locked in a competition for
influence in the Middle East most people
don't think of it in that sense but in
fact if you why would you be concerned
if you earnest really just about the
nuclear side yeah if there's an
expansion of other nuclear powers in the
region but really it gives Iran a
leverage that makes it more influential
in the region and equal in some respects
to Israel which is presently the only
nuclear power in the region so that
unique position is broken down plus if
you assume that the way Iran does a deal
is some kind of a deal with the United
States because I think that's what
everybody is talking about that is scary
not just to Israelis but it's scary to
the Arabs too because they remember the
days of the xiong and the United States
was the Shahs there
best friend and we had an arrangement
with Iran that was actually that was our
number one you know ally in the region
and I know very well that a you know
I've had real serious discussions with
high-level officials in the Arab world
who said you know oh you know we warned
you about attacking Iraq and we know
that the real result of your attack on
Iraq is to increase the power of Iran
you did away with the balancing
influence of Iraq you wipe that out and
Iran's power has skyrocketed and we
don't believe for a second that you
weren't thinking about that when you did
it we think that you've got some kind of
a secret deal in the works that you're
working out well viewed from Washington
that seems surreal and viewed for almost
any place in the United States it seems
surreal but yo the surreal is the real
when you get to the Middle East and a
lot of people were thinking that way so
I think there is a concern my guess is
that if the United States worked out for
ifs a step-by-step relationship with
Iran in which they permitted a certain
amount of enrichment of uranium but in
turn imposed very very strict you know
inspections of Iran's facilities and
there was we opened a let's say up a a
small if not an embassy at least a
intersection in the region where we had
people there representing us and lifted
some of the sanctions and things began
to move in a slightly different
direction
that's actually a very big order but
it's not impossible
my guess is Israel and the Arabs would
survive that shock
they would find a way to live with it
and they would find that it was not the
worst of all possible worlds and so from
my point of view as an American who
would like to see a different set of
policies where war is not the only
answer to our dilemma that seems to me a
way out but it's more a diplomatic way
out than it is a war-making way out and
you have to deal with the perceived
threats on all sides as you go that's
what diplomacy is all about yes if you
from the Iranian side you know Iran is
it has an atrocious political system and
the Iranian regime has committed
numerous criminal acts against its own
citizens but Iran over the past 32 years
has not committed an act of aggression
against another state Iran doesn't have
any border conflict with any of the
countries surrounding it Iranian would
never admit it but they definitely feel
insecure about this uncontested freedom
of action through freedom of military
action Israel enjoys in the region
Israel went to Lebanon Israel went to
Gaza Iranians issued a lot of propaganda
statements but they did absolutely
nothing absolutely nothing
so the idea that both the two wars in
the region as well as Israel's two wars
in the region since 9/11 has really
intensified the sense of insecurity
throughout the region and Iranian are
very much undecided feeling insecure
therefore the idea of having a deterrent
capability is something very attractive
and appealing
that's question please hi my name is
Mimi Honoka and I'm a PhD candidate at
Columbia and I was what did you take
them like Fidel yeah my name is Mimi I'm
a PhD candidate at Columbia and I had a
question about the role of this content
in the broader context of the Middle
East in South Asia given the lack of
diplomatic ties
you mentioned and also given the
potential for the arms race that you
mentioned I was wondering if you see any
role for any state or actors in the
broader Middle East or South Asia that
could be brought into a conversation in
some format of multi-party talks if the
two countries are now at loggerheads or
if that's not really even the
appropriate solution well you know that
you know there there has never been a
shortage of people of countries and
people willing to mediate some with good
intentions some with not some with
others I'm always you know you know my
my principle on this an advice would be
you if you if you're going to use a
mediator the media is very useful when
two parties are you know refuse to talk
to each other you know tell your mother
to pass the salt that's the situation
you're in be very useful but also there
are there are others who have other
purposes and we saw in the case of for
example iran-contra we saw we're unwise
mediate mediators could create to create
serious damage I my rule of thumb on
this is if someone comes to you and says
I want nothing for myself out of this I
just want to serve both sides run as
fast as you can the other what the other
way sighs smell a rat in a situation
like that but I would point to some very
useful examples of mediation certainly
the the mediation that both the Germans
and the Algerians did back in back in
1980 and 81 that got us out of got me
and Barry Rosen and some of our other
friends out of to out of Tehran was very
helpful and very very professional and
very patient very patient the mediation
that our Omani friends have
done recently involving the case of the
three imprisoned three imprisoned hikers
whose terms by the way are now
approaching the length that we are 14
months that we did that we did again
very useful but it's it's it's very
delicate and I would say it didn't use
it you know working with me working with
mediators in this case demands what any
negotiation demands demands great deal
of patience a great deal of persistence
and a great deal of self-restraint nice
question my questions in regards to our
recent attempts at civil civic appraisal
and in Iran by Iranian people do you
think there's a chance in the next five
years that the Iranian people will be
able to band together and actually
overthrow the government and how weak
with the regime really have to be for
such an event to take place without mass
chaos week letter did he know did did
people hear that question okay it had to
do with what is the likelihood over the
next five years that there would be an
internal change of government in Iran
because of popular discontent
you know it's because we have to
understand that the coercive apparatus
of this estate has a sense of identity
with this day they have interest they
come from overwhelming majority of them
they come from the lower middle-class
sectors of the society the urban poor
sectors of the society so they are not
luck Shahs soldiers and police officers
who didn't have a sense of identity and
connection with the rulers this this is
entirely different
the Iranian population has doubled over
the past 32 years and if expansion of
population is largely in urban poor and
rural areas and not in the middle class
and educated sector of the society so
the regime has a social base and the
social base is lower to the
and ideology to the extent that ideology
plays the role in Iranian politics it is
actually convincing that the apparatus
of coercion that what they are doing is
morally justified beyond that ideology
is confined 'mentally a tool at the
service of power but when it comes to
influencing the base of the society and
and the security and the intelligence
and the jailers and so forth
any other team plays the role the
hospitable majority of those people come
from the more traditional low and middle
class sectors of the society therefore
they are vulnerable to that kind of
ideological propagation predicting the
course of events in inside Iran is a
notoriously bad business my I mean here
we are we're supposed to be experts and
I I think my own my own percentage is
about is about 300 which would be great
if I were a baseball player but but not
very good as a as a political analysis I
mean Iran for what for whatever reason
has this wonderful characteristic maybe
what makes things so fascinating of
defying the experts I mean after the rev
after the Revolution you had so many
experts staying pointing with charts and
fit with charts and figures and all
kinds of reasons saying this can't last
the middle come the the educated middle
class is gone the tecnique rats or the
technocrats are gone the oil industry
the oil industry they're not investing
in the oil industry they're picking
fights with their with their neighbors
they're diplomatically isolated they're
economically miss mat mismanaged you
mean you could you could pile up the
reasons why this thing would last and
there's and they're still here 30-some
years 30 some years later so I'm very
very cautious on the other hand you
could say having said that and I wish I
could be as categorical as as dr. firing
you know they could be gone tomorrow I
think there's a frigate I think there's
a fragility there and there's a feat
there's a there's a fear there judging
by their reaction
to their own to those who criticize and
question
the course of recent events I mean this
is this these were not the actions of
those of a self-confident regime in my
opinion could I just add one quick word
on that because I I I agree very much I
think there's good news and there's bad
news and I couldn't agree more with John
that there is a that that Iran has the
capacity to surprise if you look at Iran
simply as a repressive society which
it's becoming really an authoritarian
not an authoritarian after talat aryan
society is moving very much in that
direction their capacity to hold down
opposition is really very great and you
know Stalin lasted a long time after
people ceased to believe in that system
this group could last a long time on the
other hand there are it's a gerund talk
we see at the top to a considerable
degree at least some of the people at
the top I say that with great reluctance
because actually Khamenei and I are
about the same age and I don't feel like
I'm going to kick off tomorrow but on
the other hand all of these rumors that
he's going to I I listen to with mixed
emotion but the reality is that I think
whatever happens we are going to be
surprised that things happen internally
that you don't anticipate this current
battle between Ahmadinejad and Khamenei
which is just on the verge of breaking
out into the open it's something that
really I don't think any of us would
have predicted a year ago and especially
right after the election so things can
happen things can change and you know as
someone who was in the White House at
the time would be original Iranian
Revolution I can tell you that people
were surprised and that they have that
capacity to be surprised again next
question please
hi I'm yeah a Wellner my freshman here
at the college and my question is if
Iran's nuclear program were to go
unchecked and like you said we don't
know how developed that program is how
would it change the political and the
military atmosphere in the Middle East
do you think it could spark an arms race
would it changed the balance of power
and what would be the consequences of
such a change
I agree actually with with Richard in
his initial comments that the chance
that there's going to be an unbridled
arms race in the Middle East I think is
not as likely there's a lot of pundits
who made it appear people affect adjust
to changes so if Iran gets a nuclear
weapon which I frankly don't think is
likely certainly not in the next five
years if they get a nuclear weapon in
the next 10 my guess is as that
countries in the region will adjust to
it in their own way
some of them might decide that the only
answer to this is to go ahead and
develop a nuclear weapon of their own it
seems to me we're putting some things in
place that try to see that that doesn't
happen that for instance the UAE now is
getting ready to go into nuclear power
in a major way but it's going to be
peaceful nuclear power and they have
they have actually signed very very
stringent regulations about how their
nuclear program will be run which
they'll have a hard time getting out of
and will have a hard time changing if if
they should change their mind if Iran
had a nuclear weapon tomorrow people
would rely more on the United States for
defense it's that simple
they know they can't rely on themselves
and they would look more to us to do it
and you can look on that as being a
terrible thing on the other hand it
would probably mean that our influence
in the region would go up substantially
over where it is now with a lot of the
Arab states so these are really
complicated questions and anytime you
get sort of
five 10 15 different balls in the air at
once and interacting with each other the
proposed you know predicting what the
outcome of that is going to be is very
very chancy and you're probably going to
be wrong
next question please my name is Anne
Phillips a little horse I'm sorry I'm on
the board of the International Peace
Institute in the world Policy Institute
I also have the privilege of being a
member of Gary six MIDI seminar group
what I want to know is this during the
Bush years it was more than a rumor was
spoken and I I'm not sure that it was
actually in print I think it was but it
was kept rather quiet that Iran had
reached out to the bush administration
and then the stories have died out and
in one of the Mideast seminar meetings
the previous ambassador from Iran who
was very well liked and very popular in
the United States spoke to us and said
unequivocally that the Iranian
government had written to the Bush
administration trying to reach out and
an attempt to engage them and he said
that they did not turn them down they
simply did not answer the letter my
question is why I mean it seems that it
would have been in our national interest
to have responded in particularly a time
when we were gearing up at war elsewhere
to have had a relationship with Iran or
a friendlier relationship with Iran
we're certainly in our national interest
why was this done I'm perplexed it's a
very interesting question in fact that
proposal revealed something significant
about the nature of the Iranian regime
this is that this is in May April 2003
Taliban is overthrown Saddam Hussein is
gone very quickly Iranian czar really
his courage and from the position of
weakness they want to approach the
United States and they write it the
letter has been published actually it's
delayed it oh yeah the letter has been
published in two or three different so
it's it's out of and at the same time
there is a president ha Tammy who had
always been interested in rapprochement
with the United States since the
beginning of his presidency in 1997
except that in the beginning he was
facing that the double containment
policy and toward the end when President
Clinton tried to approach him then in
Iran he didn't have sufficient influence
in order to pursue his interest but
after the overthrow of Saddam Hussein
and the Taliban his persuasive power
increased significantly and he was the
one who managed to get the cooperation
of Ayatollah Khamenei and center
on this side this is the time that the
United States has reached its the peak
of its self-confidence the peak of its
arrogance ya sat down the same is gone
Taliban is gone you know the mission is
accomplished and we have done this and
there were people who say we can do the
same thing to Iran as we did to Taliban
and Iran this is no time to engage Iran
this foot in the situation this is and
then time when our eruptions Afghanistan
changed Iran changed and all this and
for what you have done is you have put
your finger on one of the unfortunate
realities of the last 30 years of
us-iranian relations their their their
different way people have used different
metaphors some people say they Zig when
we zag the journalist Barbara Slavin
referred to to adolescents maneuvering
about who's going to invite whom to the
prom no one comes forward the other goes
back and each side is but you you can't
get you can never seem to get to the
same place at the same time
and a similar thing happened in 2000
where the Clinton administration made an
offer to the Iranians of talks without
preconditions on a roadmap what they
call a roadmap to better better
relations was a good offer the Iranians
couldn't couldn't bring themselves to
accept it for whatever reason for
whatever reason but this has been that
it's been the history and a lot of it
goes back to what I call one of my rules
for the rules of this relationship or
something that seems to run this
relationship which which is never say
yes to anything the other side proposes
because if you do you'll be seen as weak
and that's the unfort that's that's the
unfortunate part and the time in this
case may be that the devil was in the
timing maybe the devil was in the pin
the conceptions on both part on both
sides but unfortunately this has been
this has been the history and what has
been so difficult obviously forever for
everybody is breaking out of this of
this history and breaking out of the
assumption that if the other side is
making a proposal there must be a trick
in it and they must be out Jesus next
question please
hello my name is Ahmad Zi and I have a
quick question in regards to the fact
that and I was in Iran during a protest
and I was surprised at how organized the
Iranian security mechanism was it was
the first time I saw Iranian has been
organized in any way and it was shocking
to see like how effective there were but
moving on from that I wanted to ask you
is since Iran has been pushed to the
corners which ever hang has mentioned
from all sides
Iran has sort of shifted Iranian
establishments shift his mentality
towards how for example China and Russia
have gone through the same processes and
and adopted many of their
and I was wondering this fact that the
sanctions have finally actually have hit
the fabric of the Iranian society to
extend where it actually is causing I
was on a call in Iran and they're saying
like really is things are really looking
bad like the sanctions have really
started to hit but it is the people that
are getting really the end of the stick
and whereas Iranian government is
getting more ammunition to feed into its
propaganda whatever or its actions so
now any human rights organization in
Iran so then is a spy or agent of the US
and whatever and they can feed that to
the population so I was wondering two
points firstly how do you see Iran
changing in terms of going to the
mentality of how the Chinese and Russian
have dealt with their populations and
how would that evolve into and number
two doesn't the West think that by
putting all these sanctions on Iran that
not only are they not only have now they
have even less access to the Iranian
understanding to run running to be in
Iranian context of what's happening on
the ground
so our they closing even those little
doors that were open to the west to
actually have an insight on to Iran
thank you the prior question was about
in five years that the question was
whether there will be a base there would
be a challenge to the regime in it so
technically and regrettably
unfortunately I'm not optimistic about
that but what I see in the future is
complete militarization of Iranian
politics in Iran we are going to see and
it fits Iranian history and political
culture someone is going to emerge from
the security and intelligence apparatus
senses someone charismatic who this
person is in fact Khamenei and his
cohorts are very aware of this reality
they constantly shift them they shift
these individuals and they don't let
them I have been collecting the
statements made for Iranian military
leaders they all speak as if they're
running the country with such a
confidence and it's unprecedented in
Iranian society and politics so it may
well be that in the future after harmony
does
the comedy is called home by his maker
and there is a the the factionalism
within the regime is going to be
disruptive that rather harm will emerge
he with his vast and will definitely be
a star me but that is the flat instead
of near future I see and again in my
idealistic in my romantic view of Iran I
see a military regime being the
mediating force between theocracy and
DeMars what one of my Iranian friends
who's here
tells me that he keeps getting messages
from his contacts in Iran saying could
you send us articles and books to read
about Reza Reza Khan now I don't know if
they're doing that in order to resist
what Reza Han did or to imitate what
Reza Khan did but obviously I'm sorry
Reza Khan was the original name of Reza
Reza Shah who seized power in a military
coup first in in 1921 and then made
himself Shah in 1925 and essentially
ruled as a military as a military
dictator his nickname was Reza maxime
because he loved the maxim gun that was
his favor he was apparently very good
using the Mac you used it using the
maxim gun and he essentially he was a
military man who ruled by militant who
ruled through the military force and the
the similarities and the directions are
really quite really quite striking and
obviously they've struck some of our
some Iranian friends as well next
question please
my name is Jerome Jaffe st. John's
University and I'm a member of the mini
Seminar I wouldn't take much time to
discuss any other reason why the u.s. is
hostile to Iran other than it's an
autonomous power it's the only power
left in the Middle East that's somewhat
autonomous and it refuses to become a
client of the United States I take that
as given as the base of the of the
conflict the only way the US will move
from this position from its position
towards Iran is it faces another
calamity within that broad area of
euro-asia Africa and so forth and I
think it does and I'm surprised that no
one has mentioned the 800-pound gorilla
which is Afghanistan and Pakistan
talking about nuclear weapons if you
want to worry about nuclear weapons
think about it think deeply think about
what will happen when the United States
leaves if not in June or it'll be in
August or at the end of the year in 2011
what what basis for stability will exist
in Afghanistan given the given the power
of the Taliban the only possibility is
to bring in other nations in the area
that's the key to the change in US
policy as I see it okay to bring
stability to that area you must bring in
Iran you have to bring in India with
Pakistan and ultimately use whatever
leverage you can and I mean strong
leverage to resolve that in the apakah
Stan problem and with regards to Israel
and Palestine with the u.s. is doing
it's tolerance of Israel it's almost
unbelievable it's shameful you talk
about shamefulness you should worry
about that as having an influence on
u.s. prestige throughout the world so
I'd like you to discuss this question of
the totality of the Middle East of the
of Asia
its impact on Jerome I think as usual
you answered your own question and you I
think you did very well specify that
that what it will take to bring Iran and
the United States together and actually
I think your perception is is really
profound and it's one that is missed by
I think a lot of people who watch the
area very closely because they get tied
up in little specific points and in
reality it's the big things to change so
if something goes badly wrong someplace
else and you really need it wrong you
simply look what happened after we
invaded Afghanistan we couldn't do it by
ourselves we needed the Northern
Alliance to come with us and help us
establish some kind of order in
Afghanistan and defeat the Taliban Iran
had been supporting the Northern
Alliance for years they joined together
with us worked very closely with us did
this help to eliminate the Taliban and
then worked on a diplomatic level with
us to actually convince and all the
parties to get together on our side and
put Hamid Karzai in as president and the
Americans absolutely they've generally
welcomed that but publicly thanked Iran
for the work that they had done and then
two months later after this all taken
place
President Bush stands up in the State of
the Union address and says that Iran is
part of an axis of evil I think I for
one was left just breathless
I mean why what could you possibly
accomplish by that but it was the
triumph of ideology over a good sense
and it was really remarkable but it is
the kinds that we needed Iran in
Afghanistan and we cooperated with them
very closely and Iran cooperated with us
and then we didn't need them anymore
because they were we had a government
there so ideology takes over and we go
our own way and it's a tragic story and
and John has told this very well and we
all know this about the ups and downs
and the fact that the two sides never
seem to be able to find a moment when
they can get on the same page at the
same time I'd like to add a comment on
the use the word stability in the 1980's
the man
Anthony Parsons who had been the
Paramount British diplomat talking
dealing with they were with the Middle
East for a long time he gave a talk here
at Columbia jcho it's a seminar and he
said that if I had predicted ten years
ago the following things and he listed a
number of things including the Iranian
Revolution said if I had accurately
predicted what was going to happen in
the next ten years I would have been
properly dismissed from my job because
the things that actually happened were
so improbable and I was struck by that
as a as a nice lead off to talk and then
I went home and I picked random years
during the 20th century in the Middle
East and I tried to pick a year in which
the subsequent ten years could possibly
have been predicted and he couldn't do
it but what has happened in the region
on a decade-long scale has always
included major game-changing
unpredictable events you know weather
then Wars or revolutions or
assassinations or or whatever and I
think that one of the one of the
problems we have when we have a session
like this is that we're artificially
carving out an arena for discussion that
in fact is not an autonomous arena it is
a piece of a much more complex and
deeply embedded array of problems we
carving it out analytically because we
know about these things and we can talk
about these things but what is going to
happen over the next 10 years is going
to be with respect to Iran and probably
with respect to Iran Israel United
States triangle things are going to
happen the next 10 years that will
deeply affect those relations but are
not part of that arena whether it is in
Pakistan whether it's in Egypt whether
it's in the Persian Gulf
whether it is in Central Asia something
is going to happen that is going to
destabilize things we don't know what it
is and I think it's important to to
realize that that there is something not
artificial but but narrowly analytical
about the kind of discussion we're
having here tonight because I think we
all realize that the point that you make
that that there's a much broader context
for for for all of these things you know
when Sarah Palin becomes president we
may find a different world you know what
what what RIT what Richard has has said
points to something that is that is very
characteristic of sort of the
bureaucratic world and that is that the
kinds of things he is talking about you
simply your you simply cannot deal with
bureaucratic bureaucratically so if you
pose the question for example if you
would pose the question in 1978 what do
well you think the Shah is gonna fall
what do we do about it
the answer is beats the heck out of me
or if you ask the question what do we do
when when Iran explodes its first
nuclear weapon too hard
and this is the kind these are but
they're they're legit they're all
legitimate questions but to pose them in
a sense reveals your own lack of ability
or limitation to deal with these I think
that I think the correct term is the
black swans these these unpredictable or
unexpected unexpected events question
thank you very much for your talks and
my name is father she's the I'm a PhD
student at Columbia University
well quite contrary to what dr. Limbert
coded Academy Sajjad for saying that
Professor President Obama citing some
side eetu Iranians shifts basically the
burden of bringing real change into
Washington from from Washington and
moves it back to any other place I
believe that there has been a
consistency in the policies on both
sides both Washington hasn't changed
that much and Iran hasn't changed that
much and my question is more basically
towards the second part of it which is
the change in Iran which I was last year
in summer there before the election and
in the heated you know conversations and
debates about the election it seems that
there was this misconception that people
believe that oh if Medina dad doesn't
get reelected then things will not be as
bad as it was and he exacerbated
everything while looking back in you
know scrutinizing in the history of Iran
nuclear Iran's nuclear activity we see
that it was actually in 2004 when Iran
broke the seal of IAEA in Natanz for the
for building the centrifuges and this is
a time of Khatami then in 2005 before
even Ahmadinejad coming into power in
August
Iran has started officially the
enrichment of uranium and I think rather
than just making some stupid remarks
that sometimes has made the Israeli
regime happy what is the role of
Ahmadinejad do you really think that he
has a significant role they just make
some remarks that are really stupid and
makes Israelis happy
then what but it seems that there is
this consistency in the policy that it
was the same thing during cata me and
it's the same thing during Ahmadinejad
let me let me say I don't disagree with
you you have the advantage over me many
people in this room have the advantage
over me of having been to Iran much more
recently I haven't been there for 30
years not by choice
I'm just not welcome but you're exactly
right the old habits die very hard pat
old patterns die very hard they're very
tough to break as we have discovered on
both so on on both sides of the divide
on the divide and when things get
difficult as they inevitably do what's
the easiest thing to do it's to fall
back into what you've always done I mean
I hate the phrase the comfort zone I
hate that phrase but that's what it is
to do what you're most comfortable with
I would say sanctions are a perfect
example we know how to do those we're
pretty good at that we've done those
we've done those a lot but doing
something else you know changing this
ranging this were this very unproductive
relationship for 30 years that's hard
and that's very tough and when as I said
when when things get to get hard and I
think this applies on both sides of the
divide the easiest thing to do is to go
back to the patterns of the past next
question please
hi my name is Ali hi Dave and I write
for ips and Jim loaves blog and my
question is related to this one in a mr.
Lynn Brett's answer that um whether in
the next I mean we see the Obama
administration totally frozen for about
the past three months in the next two
months at least with the elections and
then in no time after that it's going to
start up with the next presidential
election and likewise in Iran there's
going to be some hardline candidate and
I'm wondering if any of these leaders
whether it's hum an a or I meant in Asia
or Obama or any of these people can
soon get past their domestic political
concerns that would have proven to be an
obstacle towards striking any kind of
deal son Iran that would be the kind of
hardline military and religious
political structures and here in the US
it's places like the Congress that are
often even Democrats in the thrall of
the Israel the so called Israel ah be
and um if I can just ask one additional
question that you guys have all said
that you see a deal is possible and I'm
wondering if you have any ideas on why
the Obama administration doesn't move
more towards the turkey brazil fuel swap
deal rather than continually insisting
on the october last October's geneva
fuel swap deal thank you could I just
say first of all I'm glad to meet you
BECU I've been posting your stuff all
the time and so actually somebody asked
earlier on what kind of sources are
available to follow these things and
there really are some good ones and the
the lady from Tehran Bureau is one good
example of that that's a really terrific
organization this organization called
enduring America or EA world views it
now calls itself is really good and you
know Jim lobes log and there's some
other places that are really excellent
sources of things that are actually
happening inside that follow things very
closely and you know they're so
information really is available could I
just say one word and I don't you know
have a nice clear answer to your
question but I do think that there is a
part of this has been about what is the
real role of Ahmadinejad in the whole
thing if you're looking for places where
changes might occur it seems to me to
put it very simplified enormously he is
trying to greatly expand the role of the
presidency he's using his second term
and is actually in a competition with
the Supreme Leader over the role of the
press
he's trying to impose his role on the
system now he may fail completely but in
the process of doing that things change
and there are impacts that part are
influenced by this and this is the kind
of thing that can surprises and that is
also the kind of place where a military
leader could actually emerge is that if
things fall into some kind of chaos you
will have some military guys saying we
cannot stand this kind of chaos we need
to re-establish order and I'm the one
that can do that and then the whole
situation changes then you have a whole
new cast of characters a whole new
possible set of possibilities and all of
these things that we're talking about
simply go out the window and you start
all over again okay I'm going to take
these last two questions then give each
of the panelists a minute or two to to
make any final remarks so please thank
you very much for a very interesting
panel questions and answers actually
when I looked at the poster downstairs I
was thinking to myself why don't we ever
organize a panel on peace between Iran
and the US and we're constantly talking
about war so perhaps perhaps this could
be an item for the for the future I
think it was Professor bullet who made a
comparison between Iran I'm sorry
between the u.s. foreign policy in Iraq
during Saddam Hussein in particular 19
with respect to 1990 to 1994 and the
2003 war especially and compare that
with potentially potential game that may
be played here between the u.s.
and Iran I respectfully disagree with
that comparison because Iran is not
certainly Iraq Iranian people are not
Iraqi people and the Iranian ruling
elements are not Iraqi ruling elements
so I don't think that comparison could
be quite quite exemplifying my second my
second point is that my second point is
that please be respectful
my second point my second point and
actually a question is that if the US
were to attack Iran can anyone in the
panel elaborate on what could be the
potential power that Iran can exercise
in the region okay thank you thank you
anyone want to look look let's take the
last question and then and then
collectively deal with these last two
because we're running at the end of our
time hi my name is Rami Montessori and
I'm a student here at the law school I
have two questions one is the what do
you guys think about the relationship
between Ayatollah Khamenei and the
military and the second one would be
what about the role of Saudi and China
because Saudi Arabia exercises a
significant power in the region right
now and if Iran and America develop a
more relationship it would be against
Saudi interest so what would you say
about that okay so we have three three
topics from table one is you know Saudi
and China one is Khamenei and the
military and one is the the question of
what what what war would do to change
the Iranian power posture if house
proper summary okay that's I thought I
said that who would like to take what
actually you know let us have our final
comments and and combined answers to
these questions if they're suitable I'm
sorry yes how a competition in Iran is
not collective it's it's highly
personalized how many from the day one
of the Iranian Revolution he was
commended representative in the military
establishment military at the time and
then Revolutionary Guards so he has
extensive connection both harmony and
much of his son with but it's a person
of relationship in that video and not
the relationship between a clerical
ruling elite and the coercive
intelligence and military apparatus of
this day what is an admin initial has
been serving the Revolutionary Guards
and the intelligence community quite
effectively that most members of this
cabinet come from that background and he
has given them free hand with respect to
contracts to the extent that today based
on unofficial statistic it's very
because there is no way to get to have
the information about the economic power
of the Revolutionary Guards and the
boneyards the foundation but apparently
they control up to 40% of the Iranian
economy so we are talking about an
Iranian military establishment that is
not simply a military institution in the
conventional sense it's closer to what
we have in Pakistan today that a
military institution that has penetrated
the judiciary the the information system
the economic or the import-export
business and accept that this
organization to the best of my knowledge
is not under the leadership of the
well-known individual not may not yet
and again based on my understanding of
Iranian political culture I don't see
this institution to become effective as
a manager of power after harmony he dies
unless someone emerges who could gain
the loyalty of his fellows I don't think
that person is at my division I think
the military leaders that is the
Revolutionary Guards and the
intelligence community they are using a
patina shot because they know he depends
on them and he has the money he is in
charge of the money
so when harmony does we are going to see
and the increasing expansion of the
military institution economically
security realm that is the future the
near future of Iran who will emerge
what kind of the present it's very
fascinating the present mayor of Tehran
mr. Carnevale he was a candidate for
presidency in 2005 in a very spontaneous
comment in response to a question in in
the news conference he said I want to be
a reservoir Islamic that's exactly what
he said which was really mind-boggling
that he would say that that he said here
is a man coming from the lower
middle-class background reservoir
definitely not he didn't really have any
royal blood at all
you know his granddaughter was my
student at Bennington College and once a
French professor came to me and said how
does it feel like to have princess as a
student I said she is the granddaughter
of the peasant soldier so someone from
that institution is going to emerge with
the populistic with lower middle class
background Ahmadinejad himself is an
interesting however obnoxious he might
be in his incendiary the state
from the sociological and historical
perspective the God has come from an
absolutely Nova to become president of
their country and attract - he is gone
mad with respect to so we really need a
psychoanalyst to tell us about at Medina
John not political scientist or or
historians but he is not the person who
will be the uncontested or the dominant
leader of the intelligence and coercive
apparatus at the present time he is an
instrument at their disposal who will
emerge I hope I'll be alive to see okay
good I want to just go back to question
that I think mr. Gotti mr. I think that
you you write about alike about
elections or particularly from it from
the American side I don't agree with you
I don't think I don't think that Iran is
a big election issue in this country in
this country there are there are there
is a small group of us and probably 80%
of that group is in this room tonight
that care very deeply about these issues
about these issues but I think most of
the electorate does not and when to give
you an example when when candidate Obama
during his primary raised the issue of
the need to change the route to engage
with Iran's and need to change the
relationship he came under very heavy
attack from not from his prime
Democratic primary rivals including the
current Secretary of State and later on
from his Republican rock from his
Republican rival and it seemed to make
absolutely no difference at all in the
campaign the election was won he won the
election anyway and he won it on on on
other issues so I wouldn't agree I
wouldn't accept necessarily that
electoral politics are going to paralyze
efforts to engage engage Iran just on
the last issue no I teach it the I teach
at the at the Naval Academy and my
my one mission is to teach our
Department of Defense colleagues that
Iranian threat is not one word and that
and that there are other aspects to this
culture and hiss and history and
politics um other than threat you know I
think I think we you know we're we're
not maybe a representative panel in the
sense that we you know none of us want
to see a war with Iran I think all of us
believe it would be a grave mistake on
our on the on the United States part
with very negative consequences
throughout the region and in this and in
this in this country it would be a
foolish thing to do
however just because something is a
foolish thing to do doesn't mean
somebody out there isn't going to do it
and we have enough enough history of
that I think this is this is a this is
an issue worth watching and I applaud
all of you for your interest in this
issue and your passion and this issue
and in the hope that we can save
ourselves and our Iranian friends from
consequences of a very what would be I
think a very grave mistake let me just
take some of the questions in reverse
order very very quickly I'm sure
everybody wants to go off and have
dinner the first was on the Saudi
Arabian China is an interesting question
it opens another whole bag of worms and
but I think we're seeing a more active
China than we have in a long long time
and all of the old truisms about the way
China behaves is are not proving to be
very reliable and I think that if you're
looking for areas where you might be
surprised
and use that as a way of measuring what
might happen in the future that's one of
the places to look
Khamenei in the military I think it's
quite an easy question to answer they've
got him surrounded basically in the name
of security they determine who gets in
to see him where he goes what he does
they don't tell him what to say on the
other hand they say whatever they want
to and he never contradicts them ever
and that's an interesting relationship I
personally share very much the view that
it's going toward a militarist Society
and there I would take exception to the
statement earlier that Iran is not Iraq
I've made that statement many many times
in my life I would say that Iran today
is trying to become Iraq Saddam's Iraq
they're working themselves in that
direction with military control and
repression replacing any sense of
legitimacy or belief in the system it's
turning into pure repression and as that
rises they look more and more like
Saddam's Iraq and that worries me very
much the fact is Iran has a lot of cards
that they can play in the region there's
no shortage of things that they can do
they can make our lives much more
difficult in Afghanistan in Iraq and
Lebanon and in other places as well and
if any kind of a crisis breaks out they
will also make our lives very very
difficult with regard I mean just
imagine what happens if an oil port in
Saudi Arabia suddenly must mysteriously
explodes and is not available for
tankers coming in you don't have to
block the Strait of Hormuz that sends a
shiver through the entire oil market the
price of oil doubles very very quickly
and the world goes back into
a another recession and if not worse and
that is that's what I mean when I say
the consequences of this are so grave
for nothing because your chances of
actually successfully getting Iran to do
exactly what you want it to do are so
limited that no sane person will do it
and although I do realize that insanity
is sometimes happens in politics I'm
betting that in this case it won't in
any case if that's an optimistic note
that's where I would like to end I'd
like to thank the panel